In this video, we'll take a look at the website for Backbones JS.
Now everything I do in this lesson you can do on your own.
So if you're feeling especially brave, pause the video right now and
explore the site on your own.
And remember that we're just looking for a high level picture of backbone.
We're not trying to get into the nitty gritty.
This page here, Backbonejs.org is actually the documentation for backbone.
Now we're going to look through this page and get an idea of what exactly
backbone is, and roughly how we can use it from a high level perspective.
The first paragraph bolds a couple words, models, collections, and views.
So we can infer that,
the models are our data and collections are collections of models.
In our original model view octopus paradigm.
We just had normal arrays.
In our model view, view model paradigm with knockout, we had observable arrays.
In Backbone, they're called collections.
And we also have views with declarative event handling.
We'll get an idea of what that is, in just a moment.
Let's scroll down a little bit and just skim through the introduction section.
The first paragraph says when working on a web application that involves a lot
of JavaScript, one of the first things you can do is to stop tying your
data to the DOM.
It's all too easy to create JavaScript applications that end up as
tangled piles of jQuery selectors and callbacks, all trying frantically to keep
data in sync between the HTML, UI, your JavaScript logic, and in some cases,
not our case, the database on the server.
So this sounds very familiar.
This is what lesson one was about.
Writing a spaghetti code application and
figuring out, you know maybe it's not good enough.
The second paragraph says, with backbone you represent your data as models.
Which can be created, validated, destroyed, and
saved to the server, if you have a server.
Now here's the fun part.
Whenever a UI action causes an attribute of a model to change,
the model triggers a change event.
All of the views that display the model state,
can be notified of that change, so they're able to respond accordingly,
re-rendering themselves to this new information.
This also sounds familiar.
This sounds exactly like what Knock Out was doing.
Keeping track of the way things are connected, so that way it can
selectively re-render certain parts of the view when the model changes.
In a finished Backbone app you don't have to write the glue code or
the octopus code or at least a lot of it, that looks into the DOM to
find the element with a specific ID and update the HTML manually.
Instead, when a model changes, the views update themselves on their own.
Now, I'm going to stop here.
At a very high level, it's basically the exact same thing as we've done before,
keeping our concerns generally separated from each other.
Now, if you look around on the web,
you'll find all kinds of shaky statements about what Backbone is.
It's not Modelview Controller, MVC.
If we look on Wikipedia, we'll find that Backbone.js it says, is based on
the model-view-presenter and the Actor model application design paradigm.
So we're not going to talk about this second part.
But if you read the rest of the Wikipedia article,
at least as of now when I'm recording this lesson.
It doesn't mention MVP ever again.
Now, this guy named Addy Osmani, who's a developer who really understands this
stuff and who wrote the code we're going to be modifying, wrote a blog post
about this, Understanding MVC and MVP For JavaScript and Backbone Developers.
This sounds like a wonderful article for us.
Unfortunately, it's really, really long so
I'm not going to go over it right now with you.
But I would like to point out one particular area of it.
About halfway down, he says, in this respect contrary,
to what might be mentioned in the official documentation or in blog posts,
Backbone is neither a truly MVC/MVP nor MVVM Framework.
It's in fact better to consider it a member of the MV* family,
which approaches architecture in its own way.
There's nothing wrong with this, but
it's important to distinguish between classical MVC and MV*, should you be
relying on advice on classical literature on the former to help with the latter.
In other words, what he's really saying is,
Backbone doesn't exactly follow, the MVC model view controller, or
model view presenter, or model view, view model parallax.
Backbone kind of does things a little bit differently.
So now we know a couple things.
Definition like MVC and MVP and MVVM.
Are not the be all end all.
We also know that MV asterisk,
means patterns that do it differently form our traditional patterns.
And to make things stranger if you read a little bit more between the lines,
you'll find that Backbone is pretty agnostic about how
you organize the communication between the different parts of your application.
So what we're going to do,
is we're going to rely on the code that we're editing.
To dictate how things are done.
And we're going to check the documentation when we need help or
when things don't work.
So, it may seem strange to say, but in order to make a few changes to
a particular project, sometimes we don't have to understand it fully.
Its important that we remember, we're looking for
a general organizational picture here.
Not a super detailed one.
We aren't going to learn backbone.js really really well.
All of this documentation is here to help us,
we're not going to understand what every single piece does.
If we had to learn a library 100% before we could make any changes,
that would be impractical and unsustainable.
Let's take a step back from all of this and,
talk to Jacques, one of our Front End Developers.
About strategies that we can use, to start adding to a project,
without the code that we add, sticking out like a sore thumb.